ce que vous venez voir sur ces images ça
s'est passé mercredi le cette semaine
des tisons des feux d'artifice qui sont
tombées sur le pont jacques cartier mais
carrément sur des spectateurs étaient en
train de regarder le spectacle olivier s
considérant pourquoi les feux ont
atteint le pont comme ça non dit pas
vraiment ce qui s'est passé là pour que
cette pluie d'étincelles tombe
littéralement parmi la foule qui était
massée sur le tablier du pont pour
regarder les feux d'artifice on a pu
parler à quelques artifices et
aujourd'hui qui ont émis certaines
hypothèses premièrement julie faux
souvenirs qu'il ya eu des orages
mercredi matin il ya eu de la pluie
l'atmosphère était lourde et ça ça
pourrait expliquer pourquoi la des
pièces pyrotechniques aurait peut-être
pu monter moins haut dans les airs
ensuite il ya le vent qui aurait pu
faire dévier certaines de ses pièces il
y avait un vent du nord à ce qu'on nous
dit donc mercredi soir dans le secteur
du pont jacques-cartier et finalement ce
que certains artifices ils nous ont dit
c'est que depuis quelques années on
utilise des pièces pyrotechniques
chinoise qui seraient de moins bonne
qualité que d'autres types de pièces
pyrotechniques
du côté de la route par exemple là on
qualifie cette dernière hypothèse de
totalement farfelue on pense plutôt que
ce sont les vents qui ont amené cette
pluie d'été celle là à tomber parmi les
spectateurs on n'est pas encore
incertain des causes parce que ce qu'il
faut dire c'est que c'est nous qui avons
appris à la ronde que ça c'était un
passé alors ils sont entrés l'heure du
côté de s'explique ce de faire des
vérifications faut vraiment comprendre
ce qui s'est passé mais quoi qu'il en
soit ça que soulève quand même des
questions sur la sécurité
oui parce conseiller la sûreté du québec
qui est présente sur le pont les soirs
de feux du côté d'un ce qu on nous dit
qu aucun agent n'a été témoin de la
scène que personne n'a porté plainte ni
pompier montréal également sont présents
sur le site de l'international des feux
loto québec on va même inspecté le site
pour être certain qu'on respecte la
réglementation fédérale lors des soirs
de feux alors personne non plus du côté
des pompiers n'a été témoin de cette
scène a alors du côté la rooney ont dit
que quand on se fait avertir qu'il y a
un problème
et bien il est possible de déconnecter
certaines pièces pyrotechniques
mais comme personne n'a été averti
mercredi soir et bien rien n'a été fait
s'explique ce dit lui même avoir la
sécurité et des spectateurs
qui assistent au feu d'artifice à 15,7
plus d'étincelles eux ils vont s'en
rappeler
merci beaucoup olivier vous a prié pour
moi